hello everyone and welcome to a very
nice game from the speed chess
championship that took place in chess
calm I did I thought I wasn't gonna do
any videos today since I did like five
yesterday but then I saw this game and I
thought well it's actually a very nice
game to show so why not show it and
before we check out the game it's
Tingler and versus yan upon the ship
ding who who just recently to down
Magnus cross and in the tigers of the
sinful cup and if you take that into
consideration then he should be a
definitely very strong candidate for
that for the world speed championship ok
the dishes calm online world speech
championship and then you have an epic
who is just the beast in everything but
the the speeches championship also
involves a bullet time format so now
I've never actually seen ding play
bullets so I don't know where how strong
he will be against nip Oh in that
particular time control but here this is
a game from the blood section it's three
minutes past one so very very pleasant
you have time for everything and the
ding has the white pieces before we
check out the game I I need your opinion
on something I was contacted by a
company that created this app for
Android maybe they have it for a for
Apple as well but they asked me if I
wanted to review their app the app is
about chess but also about poker so now
I I've never actually reviewed any apps
okay I did review the play Magnus said
but that's basically just playing chess
so that that doesn't really count
so I wanted to know if you guys would
enjoy yeah you know I hear in their
review you know an honest review of an
app such as that one I don't know if you
guys enjoy poker I enjoy poker myself so
now I don't know and there will be a
link in the description below that will
take you to a poll where you will yeah
we you will be able to either say yeah
you should you should do some reviews or
no you know just don't do any reviews so
that's basically it the the first thing
in the description below takes you to a
poll and also in any comment in addition
is more than welcome so that being said
let's check out the game now we have
ding versus nipple the Blitz section 3
+1 if you're on chess calm and a boys
Allah Allah Ches askew that's his
nickname and ding is a chef house or
chef's house chef's house I believe I've
only seen that today so it didn't know
that but okay
ding opens with E 4 we have C 5 by neppo
the Sicilian defense Knight to f3 with
d6 and now D for force striking in the
center C CAP first Knight captures with
Knight of 6 all very standard stuff
Knight c3 and a6 we have the neither of
defense Bishop to e2 biding and now II
five pushing the knight back Knight to
b3 and the Bishop to e7 with Bishop to
e3 continuing development Bishop to e6
but black does the same Nepgear dink
castles and Napo castles and here the
most common move is Queen to d2 but
koonta d3 also played adding who goes
for developing the queen r2 to a light
square instead we have Knight B to d7
and now this Knight has nice control of
the b6 core but also it's at any point
he can jump over the c5 where if white
captures then black will get a rid of
his it backwards d6 pawn so here Knight
to d5 first and here we have Knight
captures on d5 sorry bishop character
Sundy 5/9 captor 75 is possible to
preserve the bishop pair but it was
never played in this position for
example if it captures efore you have to
give up a pawn to win back the pawn
Queen captures now Knight f6 if you want
to avoid losing the bishop because the
bishop had no squares here and the
knight was blocking it so here after the
Queen moves you can go go show captures
on d5 and although
okay if the material is equal but black
has a deeper a d6 pawn ax which is an
isolated pawn also not a very strong
pawn so no wonder why no one ever played
it so Bishop captures on d5 instead he
captures and now g6 and there is one
game in the database where f4 was played
striking in the center right away but
the dingos for a4 prevents b5 also
prepares to push a5 himself so and it is
as of move 13 that we have a completely
new game with Knight the e8 neppo is now
ready to push f5
with a 5 by dink now not allowing b5 b6
also I have
very nice control of the b6 square we
have F 5 by nepo
and now F 3 making an escape route for
the bishop on F 2 with Bishop to g5
offering a trade of dark square bishop
Saul so if whites rates at the nipple
gets the Queen into the game very very
successfully and now see for biding
expanding and the Queen side also
strengthened in the center at some point
ding will want to move the knight and
get to this pawn or over the b4 now
which will make a very nice a queen
sized pawn structure we have worked the
c8 putting pressure on the c4 pawn here
and now Queen to d2 pressuring the g5
the g5 Bishop here now portrays with
Bishop characters Queen captures and now
Knight to f6 the knight is no longer
needed there as the F pawn has been
advanced now Knight to e2 ding now
prepares before to take away the c5
square from black's knight and also to
prepare the c5 push at some point after
the rook of course comes to c1 and here
you don't gain anything by grabbing the
c5 square right away after before that
night can only go back there is no other
square the knight can go to
so after this 1992 with the sure we have
f4 attacking the Queen Queen to f2
binding and now Queen to e7 developing
the Queen connecting rooks and ready to
push
efore but here ding calculates precisely
and it's not an easy calculation to make
in a blitz game here dink pushes b4
controls the c5 square rook c1 see fog
are coming and he says e for is not a
problem and it indeed it isn't a problem
because after efore you can just trade
pawn captures knife captures and if
Knight captures Queen captures then
black runs into some very serious
problems after Bishop to g4 attacking
the knight you cannot defend with the
rogue because Bishop to e6 will just win
material so you have to play something
like Queen here but after this check you
again run into problems King g7 Queen to
d4 check that the King goes to h6 and
now it's just it's just terrible
position for white you can go okay three
go rook to h3 the position is lost for
black so here now I was watching this
live so when it was saucy far before he
was he started to shake his head he
wasn't happy because he calculated
efore does not work so king 288 not
allowing this maneuver to come with
check and now comes Bishop to d3 by Dean
we have Queen to g7 and not so d4 push
doesn't work for the moment and now
comes look a to C one nipple repeats he
has to wait and see what the Dean will
do and now rook F the e1 we have looked
the c7 and now comes Knight to b3 now
that the b-pawn has been pushed and here
ding prepares a very nice maneuver also
the knife from b3 supports C 5 nicely if
needed with rook F to c8 and they put
doubles up on the C file but now comes
Luke the c2 here being with ideas maybe
of also doubling up on the C file to
further prepare c5 we have came to g7
and only now that the king came to g7
now dingos for Knights to d4 and now
there's a threat of just Knights to e6
check as the king is now in g7 to win
material here so here we have Knight the
f8 preventing what not preventing what
the night now guards d6 square so it's
not a problem and now Dean finds a
beautiful move
you can even pause the video and try to
you know just just just what would you
play here in this position so for those
of you who found Bishop to f5
congratulations as it is an excellent
move and won the ding plate and for
those of you just want to enjoy the show
yeah it's Bishop to f5 here of course
the better cannot be captured because
just check and you lose the Queen and if
you don't grab the bishop now the e6
square again becomes available to the
night because then you then you place
your disappear and then well that will
be a monster Bishop and here ok we look
back to a a the rook is under attack you
have to move it and the now comes Knight
the e6 width check with Knight captures
Bishop characters and now Knight to d7
we have c5 now finally advancing the c5
point D captures and c5 and here before
recapturing first giving up the the
monster the ship with Bishop captures
here because you want to remove
one of the defenders of either of the
pawns so here rook after sandy seven was
played and now rook captures in c5
defending the pawn here and here look
back to d8 by nepo pressuring the d5
pawn and here everyone thought ding-ding
was gonna go either Ruby want to defend
the d5 pawn or Queen to d2 or queen to a
two just the guarding the pawn here but
here Dean just played d6 and it's a it's
a very interesting move he says okay
your king is wide open I'm giving up
this point for this point and I'm gonna
make you oh okay never played the rook
after Sandy's sex with rook C capture
sunny five the queen has to move Queen
to f6 and now rook the e7 check and now
nepo
escapes to h6 looked at King to g8 seems
to be the way to go but nipple prefers
King to h6 as it seems to be a safer
Square the black Queen covers the h4
square so there are no checks from this
pot this side but here
ding has to go for rook captures on b7
because not not that obviously and
there's the threat of rook to be 2 and
it's it's a pretty big threat and here
ding spent a couple of seconds
calculating and he in he decided to go
for h3 h3 is too slow he had to go for
rook a person b7 which counters a rope
to d2 and now if Luke - D - just Queen
to a7 and you don't have a good good
response to this you have to go King to
a rook to h8 - guard upon but not just
king h1 and now you don't even have
Queen to d4 check to trade Queens and
here white is just better
but being thought that he needs an
additional safety square for the king he
played h3 but now nipple goes who look
to d2 and now it's different yes okay
you can go Queen a7 but then you go
Queen a7 without a threat so here we
have Queen to c5 just getting the Queen
out of the way and now neppo goes for
Quinta b2 Queen to h4 also a possibility
but never prefers Queen to be - just
going after the B to pawn GT pawn and
now it seems that all of a sudden being
had a wonderful game everything was
going for him he was on the attack but
now it seems that neppo is on the attack
what happens here how do you how do you
defend here if you're doing
with white so it's not easy feel free to
pause the video and try to find the best
move for white in this position while I
give you a few seconds so for those of
you who were able to do it
congratulations on being a magnificent
defender and for those of you who just
want to enjoy show it's either
well kink the h1 so if you found this
really just congratulations you just
don't allow this capture to come with
check and basically black doesn't have a
better move black has to capture so
after rook captures and g2 now what
you've done is that you've disconnected
the room the rooks no longer protect
each other and that's very important and
now you have rook captures on h7 that's
the point
so after King captures you will have
Quinta a seven check with a double
attack and also if the Queen blocks with
Queen Queen to g7 then it's not a
problem now you will just go Quinta h h4
check you can pick up in the other rook
again with check you'll pick up the rock
on G 2 so this will not be not be an
option you will have to go King to h6
and now just Queen to h4 check and you
have a perpetual since black is not
allowed to block with the Queen King g7
just 27 checking goes back you can never
go to the background because the rook
will fall with a width check so that's
one way to do it after the screen to be
to move king the h1 and there's also the
other one which is well which is a route
to f7 it's just much much much weirder
it's quite similar after rook captures
and G 2 this time rook captures and G 2
comes with check that that's why it's
weirder so if any of you found rook to
f7 that's super weird but you know
congratulations because after rook
captures and g2 King f1 and rook to g3
now not allowing this capture to even
exist also you threaten Queen to G to
mate now you again have route captures
at age 17 captures and now well with
again with the same chair 27 check now
you block with the Queen Queen to g7 and
now it doesn't work again so we cannot
block with the Queen you have to go back
kink the King goes to h6 and now again
Queen to h4 check came to g7 and Queen
to e7 so again you have a draw so it
would seem that after nip was going to
be
to move the best thing has is a draw but
Dean says I don't need a waiting move
like king to h1 or look to f7 ding plays
rook to h7 right away so everyone was
like what what what is this and but you
know he's doing he so could be could be
working but nipa played King captures on
h7 Queen to e7 check and now we have
Queen to g7 because now in this line
this is possible the rooks are still
connected and you don't have any any
checks on h4 followed by Queen captures
and e8 if the King goes to the back rank
because now after Queen to h4 check King
to g8 now you don't have you don't have
the capture King to g8 is not a
possibility so we have looked up East 7
biding continuing the attack Quinta h8
knepper offers a queen trade and now
Queen g5 threatening Queen captures and
then just delivering checkmate but a
nipple goes rogue back to d6 adds
another defender to the g6 pawn now we
have Quinta h2 did improves the position
and now Queen to f6 and it was in this
position unmoved 44 that Dingley were
and resigned the game as there is
nothing more to do he's down a whole
rook and he doesn't have any
compensation for it so really just a
just an incredible game and it really
shows what what a strong player Napo is
and always it doesn't matter if it's a
bullets classical bullet to rapid nipple
can survive any position and and come
out on top every elite player in
existence has has felt this on his own
skin that nipple is just a beast so I
really thought yeah okay I've never seen
ding play bullet but is he did beat
Magnus in the single Cup in the
tiebreaks he really crushed him it was
just phenomenal to watch IIIi don't know
I had better hopes for ding in this
matchup but in the end it was nipple who
won the match III believe he was better
in every time control but in the end of
the match ended 19 to 12 in Nepal's
favor so never never emerges victorious
in this match so that's the game I do
hope you enjoyed it I would like to I
would like to thank cracker my name here
on hardwork and George Toffler for a
conversion to my channel thank you a lot
to really appreciate it
as usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank you for watching and I
will see soon checking up on your
wonderful suggestions and es we will
have a devote on the next big saga very
soon and also if you if you have the
time to check out the poll in the
description below
so thank you all I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest three day